Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob and we're picking up with the very first video on DC's future state,
specifically the new Batman right now DC's future state is basically kind of a
glimpse into the future.
The reality of this is DC is kind of giving this to us as a,
as a kind of idea of like the multi-verse has now been saved and like the Batman
who laughs was defeated.
So like here's what things could look like in the future. In all honesty,
I think this is largely being done to kind of give a lot of their writers and
artists or reprieve either that, or,
or there's something much bigger going on behind a DC comics.
The guys have been keeping up with the news.
Things are a little rough over a DC colleagues, but you know,
we're not here to speak to that. We're here to talk about the new Batman.
So this initially opens up with a guy kind of making his way through an alley,
but also gives us a little bit of insight here and basically tells us that in
Gotham city, at this future point in time,
individuals who are masks are immediately shot on site by the cops that masks
have an effect been outlawed.
Now because of the fact that we know that like Watchman for example, is,
is part of the DC multi-verse.
Now we can largely assume this is a page being taken out of the Watchman, right?
Those of you guys who read that comic, that you know, that masks and,
and really superhero antiques in general in the Watchman universe were banned by
the us government, right? So it's kind of taken a page out of that whole thing,
but this guy with a mask is immediately set upon by the new Batman right now,
a lot of the guys are probably going to find yourself asking who's the new
Batman. There's not some grand revelation here.
And the reason why is because DC revealed who the new who the new Batman was
before we even began to see a future state, right?
We know the new Batman is currently Luke Fox, right?
He's currently bat wing and the present timeline in DC comics,
but it is interesting to kind of have them pass the mantle over to somebody who
wouldn't normally we wouldn't normally expect the big question that we're kind
of looking for an answer to is why is it Luke Fox, right?
Why him and not anybody else,
but we end up finding out the reason why Batman is coming after this guy is
because this guy has committed a series of acts, a series of crimes.
And that kind of seems to be what the idea behind the masks are,
is that people who wear masks are people who are committing crimes and they're
wearing those masks to keep their identities hidden, right?
It's almost kind of a throwback to the days of the wild West,
but as one of these things where you basically have a kind of private police
force that exists in the city of Gotham, and whenever anybody's wearing a mask,
it shoot to kill, right?
Like if you're walking down the street and any of these private police guys,
they see you walking down the road, wearing a mask,
they'll get out of their car and shoot you on site. Right.
They're totally legally allowed to do that.
And there seems to be a much bigger reason as to why that's the case,
but the long and short is that Batman being the guy that he is,
of course wears a mask. And so he's almost kind of perceived,
or really even goes as far as to tell us that he's basically public enemy number
one, right. That the cops are always on the lookout for taking out Batman.
The issue is that Batman's not someone who's easily subdued.
And it's one of these things where you even see that with these two cops who end
up kind of, you know, walking up on the guy who was subdued by Batman.
And then when they kind of have a conversation, like, should we go after Batman?
They're like, no, we'll just take this guy. We'll get our, get our promotion.
And that'll be the end of that. Right.
So going after Batman almost seems to be a kind of fools errand,
but the other part of this is that we're not really given a definitive
explanation to, it was that happened to Bruce Wayne, right. Instead,
it's just kind of like somewhere along the line, Bruce, Wayne's gone by,
we even have Luke Fox kind of making this comment, you know, where he says,
I don't know how the real Batman, and then he kind of stops and says,
I am the real Batman. Right.
But the long and short of this really seems to be that Gotham C's kind of fallen
apart in the absence of Bruce Wayne. And it's kind of a question of why,
like what, what was, what was so significant about Bruce Wayne that the city,
you know, kind of fell apart.
And the reality of this is that Bruce Wayne contributed to Gotham in more than
one way, right? On one half he was Batman. But on the other half,
he was the guy who contributed financially to Gotham city,
donating money to various causes, improving neighborhoods,
different things like that. So, you know,
it was one part beating up criminals and then the other part,
trying to make life better for them. Right.
So see if you can't square that soccer,
why like I'm going to beat you up and I'm going to pay you the next morning.
I don't, I don't really know. I don't really know how you square that circle,
but that's basically what was going on in the city of Gotham.
But the other part of this is that Luke Fox's mom is actually working in favor
of the laws that allow people who wear masks to be shot on site.
And that the law itself is being challenged by the ACL. Ooh,
the American civil liberties union.
So of course they're challenging this on the,
on the auspices that killing individuals who are wearing masks is basically a
violation of their human rights. Right.
And so it makes these kind of interesting because that's one of the philosophies
we talked about in Batman comics over the years is that, you know,
people kind of say, well, I have a right to this. I have a right to that.
And it's like, okay, well then put that right in my hand, right? Put tape,
take your freedom of speech and put it in my hand, like,
like show me this freedom of speech you have.
And the reality is that is intangible. And if it's intangible,
it can easily be taken away. And so because of that, it's,
it creates a really interesting sort of dichotomy here in the sense that Luke
and his mom are really on opposing sides.
But because of the fact that their mother and son,
they still find a way to make sure their,
their parental and child relationship stays intact. But from there,
we switch over to a place called a little Santa Prisca.
What does the neighborhood inside Gotham?
And that it's really ran by a group of masks who have modeled themselves after
Bain. Now this begs even more questions, why vain? Right? Like, I mean,
I guess because he wears a mask and it's kind of the ultimate, you know,
declaration of what it means to keep your face covered and really live up to the
mask arc archetype,
but where's Bain and all this now because of the fact that this future state
event seems to exist in the future,
we don't really know if there's a definitive future.
You can largely kind of go with the idea that these guys are modeling their
philosophy off the events of Tom King's Batman.
When Bain took over the city of Gotham, regardless of, of,
of what the deal is here. A couple of kids are basically snatched up, right?
These two guys who were brothers are snatched up by this gang.
And the idea is they're trying to get them to join into the gang.
And so what they end up saying is like, if you want to be part of this group,
when there's a few things you need to understand when they kind of asked the
question, why should we join you in the first place?
The gains response here is because nobody cares now.
That's usually how gangs end up preying on younger people, right?
They kind of go to go to those who are effectively, we can desperate, right?
Those who feel cast off by society and they give them this kind of promise of
we'll be your family because of that. You know,
you have these guys who were kind of like, you know,
what's the requirement here in order for us to get into this gang,
what do we have to do? And the response is you got to kill somebody.
But the idea here seems to be that what they get in return,
that's kind of promise of family, right? The fact that they had members of,
you know, one of their parents who ran off, you know,
the promise of having a life and actually longing somewhere really seems to be
what it is that they need in order to fulfill this act.
And so what they end up doing is through a couple of throw in a couple of masks
on these guys and then basically taking them out into the street and then in
turn saying, okay, like, let's grab a target and let's kill this guy. Now,
before we do that,
I want to switch over for a second to Luke Fox going and visiting a sister
wildly familiar about that wing. But as far as I'm aware,
we weren't really exposed to that. The fact that he had a brother named Tim,
not that I'm aware of. Right. I could have, I could, I could miss that.
You know, it could be wrong about that,
but I'm not aware that he ever had a brother.
So this seems to be a new introduction. Now, if I'm wrong,
feel free to correct me in the comment. That's right.
I want to make sure that I have the correct information from you guys,
but his sister Tam is basically in the hospital. Right.
She's here because she ended up relapsing and presumably overdosing on drugs.
Right. And so that's why she's currently here, but there's,
there's a lot of bad blood between Luke and his brother himself in the sense
that his brother kind of seemed to be one of these in and out kind of guys,
you don't ever really comes around when he needs something that in the time
where he talks about, well, you know, I mean,
I came here because she's my sister and I to look now for the responses. Well,
I mean, sure you were in a military Academy,
but you've been out of there for a long time.
So what stopped you from coming back before now? Right?
Like you're only here because you know, maybe you want something,
maybe you need something,
but you're not here for her because you could have been here for her over any
amount of time that you've been free and available to come here and actually be
there for her. Right.
So we know there's kind of animosity and bad blood between the two. From there,
you ended up switching over to a guy by the name of Whitaker and of course
Whitaker's met, bye bye. A person named Chubb. Right. We can,
it looks like that's, that's, you know, her name.
I don't know if that's actually her name or not,
and maybe some kind of a nickname,
but of course she's got a new partner named Tanaka,
but the idea is a Chubb and Whitaker were, were partners at one point in time.
And she was always really close to them.
There's no indication that was romantic,
but there is a lot of indication that their friendship was exceedingly strong,
that they were very good partners and they could talk about almost anything.
But the reason why she's here is that word has reached their ears,
that a former cop, right. Which it seems like Whitaker had basically bailed out,
but like some kind of a copper or somebody who's a former cop is basically
moving through the city of Gotham and helping these different masks to achieve
crimes. Right.
To kind of give them the information they need in order to pull off different
crimes, different Heights, and then in turn disappear. Right?
And so this guy basically seems to be working against the police officers in
favor of the masks. And that's, what's,
what's so interesting about this is because we don't really have a full
perception of Gotham. We just got this little fractional depiction of it.
And so it's, it's really easy to look at this and to say, okay,
the cops are wrong because they have killed orders,
but we don't really know why they have kill orders. Why they were brought in,
in the first place. On the other hand is easy to say, well,
if those guys don't want to die, they shouldn't wear masks.
But it's one of these things where it could very well be.
The cops are the bad guys and the people with the masks are the good guys.
Now I don't really believe that people with masks are good guys because they're
walking around and just shooting people arbitrarily in order to get people into
their gang. But you know,
there's a little more we're going on here than what we're initially told.
It's kind of what I'm making a point of saying here.
What do you think about this? Is that what you end up having a, you know,
kind of transitioning back to these two kids with, uh, with this gang, right?
This, this main mass gang,
they end up running up on this one guy where they pull a gun out, but one,
the brothers stops the other and says, no, we can't do this. Right.
We can't just arbitrarily kill people in a desire to join some kind of a gang.
Now in this moment where he does attracts his brother kind of moves his gun out
of the way. And he ends up misfiring. Uh, it leads to the other guy,
pulling a gun out and firing on them. Right?
The problem with that is as soon as it's shots fired,
somebody somewhere calls a police,
or really because there's so many surveillance cameras and everything,
the cops were already aware of what's going on here, right?
Probably saw these guys wearing a mask inside their car,
but basically the sirens are not that far away.
And so you end up having Batman who jumps in and saves the life of this would be
victim, right? This, this person that they were going to shoot.
And then in turn,
Batman jumps in and starts beating the crap out of these guys who were wearing
masks. Now, one of the things that's shown here, and this is really important,
one of the things has shown here is that Luke Fox has every bit of effective of
a, of a Batman as Bruce Wayne was right. The Bruce Wayne,
his greatest skill was his ability to appear and disappear to almost be like a
Phantom,
like a ghost while you wouldn't really know he was there until he wanted you to
know he was there.
And Luke Fox largely appears to be just as capable now while these guys are
basically driving and trying to get away and trying to shoot a Batman and so on
and so forth, they ended up crashing, you know, into, into a truck.
And this really allows Luke to kind of take out the main gang members,
but then also go after the two young girls, right? These,
these two young kids who were potentially involved in this game,
but the problem with this, and what's really kind of cool here.
And the strong similarities between Luke and Bruce is that Luke does exactly
what Bruce would have done. No one, he trucks down these kids,
he doesn't just start beating the crap out of them, you know, mast, you know,
and they just start attacking him, you know, or anything like that.
And instead he realizes these two young kids were basically weaken desperate.
They were looking to belong somewhere and they could have potentially made a
choice that would have destroyed their lives more so than that.
If they were caught by the cops,
the cops would have executed them or the cops would have killed them on site.
So from there, he's kind of like you guys, like we got to get out of here,
we're going to save your lives. You know, that's, that's kind of the thing.
That's what that meant though. The smoke bomb and these cops end up firing in,
but of course, you know,
Luke gets these two kids out of there takes them off and says like,
I'm handing you guys over to child services. Right.
Whatever happens after that is, is really kind of on you. But it's, it's a,
it's a really cool thing, right?
Because we pick up with what looks like Whitaker.
And then of course Whitaker's seemingly you know,
prepared to be attached by a couple of other guys, uh, who are, who are,
you know, about potentially, you know, gang members, you know that,
or it's just some random guy, right? I mean, whatever case is here, uh,
the important thing is that Gotham is in a much darker place than it has been,
but it's really not one of those dark stories. Like the dark Knight returns.
It's one of these stories where it's potentially hopeful.
It's not dark and bleak and really, really crappy. Ah,
there's one of these things where it's like, Gotham's kind of in a bad spot,
you know, like, like often coffins, furloughed is kind of what it is, right.
He's not totally unemployed he'll but he's off of his job for a little while,
but to suck. Absolutely. Well, there's a light at the end of the tunnel, right.
That's kind of what, what, you know, where Gotham is right now. And it's nice.
I like it. You know, to be honest, the art throws me off a little bit,
but the more I kind of look at this, the, the easier it becomes to accept,
I'm just still a little disappointed because the, the art's not bad,
but it is VCs. It shipped title.
And I kind of feel like they need to have a much better artist on here. Yeah.
But nonetheless, you know, it's cool. You know, it's, it's a, it's a,
it's a great little story. Ah,
let me know what you guys think down in the comments section.
If you guys are new here to comments, explain Michelle,
you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob Ford.
You guys enjoyed this video.
Make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later,
Bruce.